I'm going to show you a little bit of a
scam or a trick that you can try out on
people so what I'm going to ask you to
do is to pick a sequence of three coin
tosses so you know heads tails heads or
tails tails tails tails toes this okay
so Brady picking tails tails heads and I
will pick heads tails tails and the game
is we're going to toss this coin and
then see who gets that first so let's
see you win we'll do best of five okay
something like that okay so let's try
game number one all right here we go
so number one all right let's write down
this sequence heads okay that's pretty
good actually that's good for me
yeah it's good for me not good for you
all right heads again heads again right
oh look at this you might have to do a
different video about how many heads we
can get in a row all up tails all right
Oh tails that is a win for me excellent
a James win brilliant
all right well best of five all right
Brady's got a tail come on ah now this
is good for me yes that's a tail yes and
it's a tail all now you okay though
yes still you're scaring me leave ya
happy with that on you all right oh
that's good all I need in fact I'm
definitely going to win this next one
soon as the secret breaks yeah you're
right well observed Brady Brady does win
that he had to win that after all those
pills coming up okay oh so so it's bad
to choose any two consecutive as you
start it is bad - geez Brady realize
what's wrong huh it's gone gone gone you
can still win this are you giving up I
realized we realized bottoms you're less
likely to win than I am so what would
you have done if I had not been stupid
and not given consecutives
as my whatever sequence you have that
you pick I can pick a sequence that is
more likely to
appear before yours what if I pick the
most likely in them all exactly why if
you pick the most likely of them all it
goes round in a circle like
rock-paper-scissors
let's say Brady picks whatever sequence
he does pick I'm going to show you what
sequence I should pick so that I can
beat him all right all be at least with
a better chance of beating him I'm going
to show you the cycle of winning let's
do that right so let's say Brady picks
head head head right three heads in a
row then what I should pick is tail
heads heads and tail heads heads will
beat heads heads heads if Brady had
picked tails heads heads that I should
choose tails tails heads because that is
going to beat Brady if Brady had picked
tails tails heads then I should pick
heads tails tails that will beat Brady
incidentally if he had picked instead
tails heads tails you pick this one here
tails tails head so it's not quite a
circle this it has some spikes coming
off the side of it with Brady it picked
tails tails tails you want to choose
heads tails tails if Brady it picked
heads tails tails then the best choice
is heads heads tails if your picks heads
tails heads I would again pick heads
heads tails if you're chosen heads heads
tails Brady I would have picked tails
heads heads so we have this little
circle but you can see the spikes coming
off it as well so to read this
Brady's choice would be here at the
pointy end of the arrow my choice the
better choice would be here so the arrow
going towards Brady's choice there there
is a way to help you to remember this
cycle the way you do it is when your
opponent picks a sequence let's say
tails heads heads what you should do is
in your mind
copy the middle one so make a copy of
that coin so I've got another heads
there I'm going to put it at the front
and flip it over so it would become a
tail
and then my choice would be tails tails
heads that's the winning choice that
little way of remembering it is better
than just remembering that cycle and and
that will work likes your best choice to
go for I should show you the
probabilities for each choice if Brady
Pitts heads heads heads
I would pick tails heads heads and the
chance of beating you it's actually
pretty good it's a 7/8 I can take us
round about like 80 7.5% so it's really
likely I'm really likely to win the game
that's why I did best-of-five though
just in case probability let me down
this probability here if I wanted to
work her tails heads heads beating heads
heads tails that happens with a chance
of three quarters so it was about 75%
really big probability if you want to do
this one here heads heads tails beating
heads tails heads that happens with a
chance of 2/3 so that's what's that
about 67% and then actually the others
are similar and this probability here is
2/3 this one here is 7/8 this one here
is 3/4 there's a symmetry in this so
you're far more likely to win hey
excellent try it out yet try it out on
your enemy's right so you can beat them
this is insane because you think well
surely there's a best choice there's the
best choice and then you know all the
others are worse than that and you can't
beat the best choice
it works in such a strange way that it
makes this cycle of probabilities
instead just to show you where these
come from those are some of the easy
ones ok I'm going to show you where some
of these come on Bo look this is an easy
one look at this I said this was a 7/8
and yeah that's it that's actually an
easy one to spot because well you could
get heads heads heads straight away
which happens 1/8 for the time if you
don't get heads heads heads straight
away if you've got a sequence and
somewhere in the sequence it's heads
heads heads they say this is the first
appearance then it has to be preceded by
a tail if it's not if it was perceived
by head then it wouldn't be
the first heads heads heads in sequence
it has to be preceded by a tail which
means it has to have tails heads heads
coming up before it unless you get the
three heads in a row straight away and
so yeah you're going to lose if you pick
heads heads heads most of the time yes
if we go back to our game and what Brady
chose he chose tails tails heads it
wasn't the best choice Brady if you pick
tails tails heads I use my little
algorithm I know what I'm supposed to
choose heads tails tails and I can beat
you and appear before yours does with a
chance of 75% which is actually like the
second best thing there oh really bad
choice Brady sorry about that well I
might not be making the best coin
choices but I have been learning a lot
of you mathematical tricks at the great
courses Plus this is a great online
resource for anyone who wants to learn
anything become smarter about things
from cookery to quantum mechanics
I think numberphile fans in particular
might be interested by some of the
mathematical offerings they really
extensive and right up the alley of the
sort of people who watch these videos
there's lots about games puzzles
probability I've really been enjoying
just today some of the videos about
probability I wish I'd watch them before
recording that video with James if you'd
like to find out more go to the great
courses plus com
slash numberphile have a look what's
there and if you like it you can
actually sign up for a one-month free
trial
that's one month's access to 7,000 plus
videos all taught by leading experts in
these fields that address again the
great courses plus comm slash
numberphile give it a look if you like
these videos here on numberphile I think
you might really like what you find
there and cheers to the great courses
plus for supporting this video this game
is called pennies game or penny ante
which i think is a kind of a pun
actually the strange thing is a penny
doesn't refer to coins and pennies and
flipping coin it's actually the name of
the guy who came up with the
with the game he was called penny it's
kind of one of those situations when you
have a baker called mr. Baker or a
mathematician called dr. sexy or
something like that